Brody Jenner's mom is setting the record
straight life is messy
Linda Thompson who appeared alongside
the reality star on MTV's the hills new
beginnings caught some flak after she
liked a post about her son's ex Caitlyn
Carter wanting attention with those
viral photos of her kissing Miley Cyrus
it's a little strange some people
thought the 69 year olds like was an
intentional dig at Brody's ex following
their split earlier this month but on
Wednesday
Linda shared this image that read quote
please don't judge people you never
truly know the daily struggles of others
she captioned the post quote how we
react and respond to life's vicissitudes
disappointments failures and successes
may we strive to do so with grace
humility temperance understanding
compassion kindness forgiveness and love
love and and forgiveness and tolerance
and understanding and educating
ourselves and moving on you know and and
just trying to be the best human being
that we can be and in the midst of chaos
and you know it sometimes hurt but but
to take the good take the good parts you
know while the moving passage was
telling enough it was the comments
section that really caught fans
attention yep Kaitlyn commented on the
post writing in all caps exactly we just
needed to say what we were really
feeling and thinking because that way
you don't get any trouble linda replied
to the comment tagging Kaitlyn with a
heart writing and for the record honey
the only shade I throw is my own shadow
walking away from drama you know I love
you I always have and always will you
have to come out the other side wiser
stronger knowing that you were you were
meant to learn something
Linda's message mirrors her son's
feelings for his ex
and their mutual friends Miley and Liam
Hemsworth a source close to Brody
previously told ET quote he still cares
deeply for Kaitlyn and his friendships
of Miley and Liam he wants everyone to
be happy and live their best life